when it comes to people who watch this
show
I think even down to the least skilled
person their survival their survival
chance in a city is going to be triple
or quadruple the average person just
because for one reason they see it
coming
you watch a news program like this we
say hey look they just deployed for
combat a massive nuclear weapon then
when the news breaks that you know like
let's say Putin comes out and says mark
my words we will fire this nuke if you
don't stop you're going to be sitting
there being like okay well I'm gonna put
my bug out back together and then when
the sirens go off you grab your bag
you're out the door other people are
standing around going I wonder what's
going on you know not to toot my own
horn but I was in Boise Idaho when the
covid pandemic alleged pandemic uh
kicked off and I remember seeing
national news about the Costco in my in
my area was running out of toilet paper
this is in January of 2020. before when
everyone knew it was nonsense and it may
have been as silly as it was for people
to suck up on toilet paper I saw it was
going on I'm like well I'm not going to
be last so I went and stocked up and
guess what I had Charmin top shelf the
excellent stuff sustained me through the
entire did you resell it for a problem
I did not resell I'm not you know he's
like he's he's in a dark alley in a
trench coat and he like opens it up you
got it you got that good stuff give me
another one
another Square man I saw a funny picture
going around where is the the Purell the
handstand someone had like a little
baggie of it like this crack and it said
hey yo text me get at me I got that good
old Purell I stopped at a gas station I
think it was in Arizona and uh nobody
was wearing masks I walked in the guest
because like in the middle of nowhere
and she's like oh we don't care they
have mandates out here but ain't no one
gonna enforce it and then I said so what
do you think are you guys worried I hear
that they're running out of toilet paper
everywhere and she's like
we're Preppers I got three months with a
toilet paper and my storage in my
storage uh area like we didn't even
think twice about it when all this stuff
started happening we just put our feet
up and started laughing and I'm like man
the Preppers they're having a good time
right now yeah everybody that or not
everybody but I imagine there's a
significant portion of the The Listener
and viewers of of the podcast here that
have taken some precautions or some
steps to you know do some type of
prepping
um if you haven't you're it's a good
idea it's not a bad idea so and let me
let me add to uh
for political reasons downloading
Wikipedia makes no sense that is to say
if you were to download the entirety of
Wikipedia because you wanted to learn
about Newt Gingrich yeah you're wasting
your time maybe go to Art go to Archive
and from five years or ten years ago and
download it but but I recommend everyone
download the full uh text of Wikipedia
because there's you if you ignore the
politics being able to read about
chemical composition drugs yeah there's
there's really basic stuff in there
that's life-saving in the event of you
know like an encyclopedia that large
look if the world ends you're not going
to be looking up Newt Gingrich you're
going to be looking up you know uh like
North American plants I have on
Wikipedia will actually create
categories where you can it'll be like
you know edible fruits native to North
America and you can click it and you'll
see all these things and they'll have uh
they'll have pictures I have I don't
know if the pictures download with the
full app though I've got this EMF
protecting case that I put a solid state
hard drive inside of that I wrap up and
then put inside of a flame
um repellent safe and that you can put
like Wikipedia on like a solid state
hard drive inside of an EMF protector
inside of a fire protected any more than
that that won't be enough so uh a buddy
of mine actually has a faraday cage a
high a high quality like government
level certified for doing uh uh tests on
Cell networks and satellites and
Communications and it does not block all
EMF it's it's like a shield that you
walk inside and you see your cell
service all the way down does EMF fry
solid state drive
I'm I'm fairly certain yeah it's going
to short out anything anything
electronic but a solid state like
circuitry they're not magnetic I know
that but so so that's not so much the
issue but with a faraday cage what you
want to do is that EMF protector you got
EMF case a little Faraday bag put in a
microwave microwave is a faraday cage so
put in the microwave and put it deep in
your basement and then if you really
want to be serious wrap it in tin foil
then put it in a bigger microwave
because you know I was talking to my
buddy and I said he's got a fairy cage I
said you know so are we you put like a
phone in there so if a solar flare hits
you're good and he's like this thing's
not going to protect that from a solar
flare solar flare is going to fry
whatever's inside of it and I'm like in
the Faraday cage like it's yeah it's
imperfect it's the the a a solar flare
or an EMP is going to be so powerful it
will get through there's going to be
leakage and I'm like what if you put a
microwave in the Faraday cage and then
put something okay now you're good right
you you double layer it and then the
fair day cage does provide protection
but the idea that these things will
protect you guaranteed it's not true
what you want to do is get a car from
the 60s yeah and then just a carburetor
yeah a non-fuel injection that's the key
because all a lot of people don't
realize all of your cars now every
single one of them operates uh with a
computer and if it's not a carbureted
engine which none of them are anymore uh
it will undoubtedly fry but apparently
though unless you're in like an
underground parking garage there might
be a chance I thought I read somewhere I
don't know if that's true
um but speaking of like we were talking
about prepping and in the context of
like solar flares a lot of people
realize I know this can be some people
realizing everything will be fine you
know it's like but a solar flare could
happen there are natural events that are
unforeseeable that have nothing to do
with you know uh geopolitical uh you
know things going on in the world and
it's just a you know when I was growing
up uh in in Arizona there's a large um
LDS Mormon population and like it's
customary uh to have like three four
months of of preps and I remember
thinking that was weird at the time now
it's like no that is that's wisdom three
months I think it's three or four months
minimum like of like food I don't know I
could be wrong it should be everybody
that should be that should be as simple
and basic as as it comes you should be
able to to sustain yourself for at least
a month by what you have in your house
even if it's like not eating the best
food but you know freeze-dried stuff or
whatever stuff that can give you
calories so you can get through safe and
readymeals.com
a not shout out shout out that we we
used to do reads for them a lot more
often but now we just basically we talk
about castbrew and you know when we
started promoting our own coffee brand
because we're opening this coffee shop I
was like we're not doing these shout
outs anymore but we used to do periodic
shout outs for safe and readymeals.com
which is emergency food that lasts 25
years now it's really funny because when
I started promoting that and I love
telling the story all these leftists
started mocking and insulting me being
like haha what an idiot what a loser
he's selling emergency food and I'm like
it's really crazy because we all have
first aid kits we rarely use them
you are willing to get a first aid kit
in the event you have a femoral bleed
but you're not willing to have food you
can eat you eat food every single day
when was like honest question when was
the last time you used a Band-Aid
uh a few weeks ago I guess like
seriously though no just on a band like
on my finger yeah what about you use the
Band-Aid uh uh an action I don't
remember if I have if I cut my finger
I'll put one like Neosporin on and stuff
just so that way it heals faster yeah I
don't use Band-Aids I I wash with soap
and then let a marriage I usually rub
dirt in it I think mine might have been
like five months ago maybe that's over
of two years for me I don't use them we
eat food every day
and people are like oh you're dumb for
having a food in the event of an
emergency they're projecting their own
insecurities deep down they know like or
or these are the same people that ran
out of toilet paper and then fought for
it yeah would it be good to have like a
giant tub of protein powder I imagine
you could make that last uh yeah what
like a year maybe not sure the day but
they have expression expiration dates
yeah but uh there there's ways to
preserve protein like freeze-dried I
mean beans beans and rice can be
preserved for 25 years we have been in
rice buckets and those form a complete
Amino chain yeah just by uh salt
allegedly you know iodized salt
um and you can season and apparently we
need iodine I don't I've heard different
things 10 buckets of salt it's so cheap
it's a good investment as well as
lighters by the way it's a random
thought plasma lighters that can plug in
I have a bunch of those and then solar
panels solar chargers that you can
charge your lighter off of I carry it
around with me in my fanny pack
I guess the bigger question is
you know what's the likelihood of
anything actually happening
and that's that's where people refuse to
take action but I'll just tell you would
you rather be the guy who spent a little
bit of money to have a bucket of food in
your basement that you might have to eat
in 25 years before it goes bad seriously
25 years or do you want to be fighting
with Agnes in a parking lot of Walmart
for the last can of beans you know it's
the peace of mind and the thing is like
so I'm a prepper myself and the thought
going through my mind is like knowing
what I know if let's imagine that the
so-called event happened and somebody
listening to us is like they hadn't
prepped and then they wake up in the
morning and the lights don't come back
on can you imagine the overwhelming
feeling of Shame and guilt and that that
that regret of like oh no I could have
just used my credit card I could have
bought this stuff I could have and I
didn't that would consume me knowing you
know what I mean like so it's like
there's no excuse anymore oh New York's
gonna be us it's going to be a a sight
to behold I don't mean in a positive way
we have never in human history seen
density to this level
we've seen great fires we've seen War
there's the the sacking of Richmond and
what it's like when these cities are
totally raised and in conflict and bolts
are flying World War II but we have
massively gained population in the past
hundred years in in in profound ways if
the grid goes down and new I was in New
York when Sandy happened and it was
already getting kind of scary you had I
went to a bodega and there's a line at
the door they only allowed one person at
a time there were two guys with like a
like a piece a stick of like a big piece
of wood and a guy with like a crowbar
guarding the store they'd let you in
you'd walk in and then I was like I was
like how's it going to the clerk and he
was like anything perishable you don't
want to eat all the stuff in the fridge
is expired but the canned stuff is good
and I was like cool and in the fridge
spoiled milk and cream and and milk
products and uh I took a Gatorade and
like some crackers or whatever and I was
like yeah it was it was dark in New York
for like two days after that flood you
were that you were there like yeah the
Lower East Side was that we had no power
like what two weeks something like that
yeah maybe two days of really dark like
weird yeah and and like the flood
damage destroyed windows and knocked
over bus stand and that's just a
hurricane and then you had um the
rockaways were just yeah that's where I
lived I lived in Far Rockaway well after
actually I moved there right after the
right after the damage it was wrecked
the whole Coastline would react and uh I
went I actually took the train down to
uh document the relief work that was
going on and it was crazy to see it like
the the the uh the boardwalks like
ripped up it's just houses destroyed
when the lights go out in a city man it
is another place it's not home it's dark
and cold and dangerous you do
not want to be in a city in the dark it
is terrifying hard pass and that's after
like two days of it being dark I don't
know after two weeks of it being dark
you're gonna see everything lit on fire
warm so I Am Legend remember Will Smith
in New York City and Manhattan
University you seen the movie yeah you
know but but again
people watch these movies and then get
these weird expectations of what things
will be like the what the first thing
you can do first the first thing I'll
say is you cannot predict what it will
be like there's there are certain things
we can say are likely and may happen but
imagine this what is your daily routine
okay
imagine you wake up for your daily
routine no electricity what's that like
I'm sure it's happened the power's gone
out you woke up there's no power what
did you do now imagine it's going to be
that way for several days if you live in
a more rural area and you're on a well
with an electric pump how are you
getting the water out of the ground if
there's no electricity most people I
think out here have backup means of
electricity for that reason solar diesel
generators gas generators Etc but just
that's one way to consider what it would
be like now the question I have free
that live in the suburbs do you think
your neighbors are smart
because if the water stops are flowing
and they can't figure it out
do you think that uh Jimmy next door
will let his 12 year old daughter starve
to death or do you think he would let's
just say cause harm to others including
you if it meant protecting his children
Jimmy will come by and knock on your
door with a smile and ask if he could
have some of your water rations that you
don't have enough of and you'll have to
tell him no and he'll leave with a smile
maybe maybe he won't be smiling as much
when he leaves the next time you see him
he won't be smiling yeah he'll be crying
he'll kick your door and if you can see
him again with the gun pointed at you
and I'll say I'm sorry I'm sorry before
he puts one between your eyes yep you
know it's far more likely I think when
we're talking about all this doomsday
stuff I look at people like Klaus Schwab
and when he speaks I think we need to
listen at this point and what was it
just two years ago he was talking about
if there was a Cyber attack it would do
us in covert would pal in comparison
anyways so a a financial attack so it
doesn't necessarily attack the entire
grid we still have electricity however
attacks the banking system and this
could be their tactic to usher in the
cbdc because a lot of people say like
I'm not going to go along with that I'm
not going to go along with that I'm like
well in this you're starving and by the
way when I look at all these these 87
000 IRS agents are they really hiring
them to check like venmo uh transactions
or is it possible that they once they
come out with the cbdc they're going to
make any other exchange of currency
illegal dollar gold anything so I got it
I got a simpler one for you
uh Act of war or financial crisis
results in deposits being wiped out
let's say the grid goes down the economy
collapses something akin to a lockdown
the government says we can ensure and we
have insured your deposits
we we have relief download fed fed Bank
from the Play Store and from the app
store right now and enter in your name
your social security number and your ID
and a picture of your ID and you will
get transferred in
well you know uh the money from your
account before it was before incident
occurred and what that does is let's say
there's a financial collapse let's say
that there is a natural disaster or an
act of war that disrupts the financial
sector the economy goes to chaos
now they simply say oh your money's gone
but don't worry we've got it right here
for you at CBD cbdc.app download today
Tim I think you're spot on and I think
this is what's going to happen is that
the way to do it isn't to force the that
new system it's to get us to beg for it
once your someone's kids are three days
without a meal they'll please give it to
me fine fine and um we'll figure
something out later we'll you know we'll
get this sorted out they're going to get
them to to to to want it that's what I
fear is that that's what they'll do
they'll mess up the system if you have
any hope of staying off of that you're
gonna need a whole lot of silver dimes
yeah I can imagine a lot of people won't
do it and then it'll create a subclass
well I mean obviously bullets but but
the silver dimes are just because
they're I think they're great like a
gray gray Market is where people are
going to be avoiding it so if you're if
you are going to have the ability to
stay off you're gonna need something
that people will recognize as money and
silver coins do that I I think it'll be
nine millimeter
even even right now I don't care about
silver I get it silver has value I have
some silver what I mean to say is if
someone comes to me right now and says
hey I'll give you a piece of silver for
uh you know that slice of pizza I'll be
like bro I don't care like what am I
what am I gonna do with that silver I
put in my closet right I understand that
you can always it's it's like a it is a
liquid asset sort of you can take it
somewhere and exchange it you can get
value for it you can trade with it it's
not that easy
your bone I can use and I'm totally with
you because like in my mind I'm like I'm
not convinced there won't be some crazy
and I'm very curious to know what it's
my life is gonna be like when I'm at
retirement age you know I feel like
something will happen whether it's a
pole shift whether it's some World War
III or whatever it is and in my mind I'm
not certain that it won't come to the
point where ammunition is currency and
everyone honestly I'm an advocate I'm a
second amendment Advocate I think
everyone it's about self-sustaining and
you need to protect yourself because
like look at Hurricane Katrina which
isn't necessarily the best example but
there was a few days there where it was
AB you know total lawlessness and there
was people that held down their
neighborhoods by their own use of force
and
um so I don't know like anything can
happen the unpredictable can happen if
people can't uh take care of themselves
you should expect that no one else will
listen and anyone that's listening that
that is of a little on the young side
that thinks it's silly the idea that a a
bullet or whatever could be uh used as
currency the reason we call a shot of
whiskey a shot of whiskey is because
that one ounce of whiskey was traded for
145 Colt long in uh back in the old west
is that what is that why he was a child
it was a shot because it was one you
could trade one round 145 Colt 45 Long
Colt usually wow for uh for a shot of
whiskey yeah so wow you know there's a
lot of stuff we can learn from the
Western times on those frontier days
when it was you know when there was
lawlessness and Marauders and the
Cowboys which were a real gang what's
What's that show 1911 or whatever no not
911 uh 1913 23 19 23 23. yeah I don't
even know the year the show is but uh uh
no no no 18 what's the 18 one uh there's
there's a couple of them it's like I
think one is uh 1893 or something ah man
uh what you're telling me right now is
don't make a show with the year is the
name I know yeah I know yeah seriously
come on who knows what is it uh because
I watched it it was awesome uh
yo that and it's like the Oregon Trail
87 1887. yeah that's what someone typed
in chat I don't know if that's true yeah
yeah they're like we gotta float the
wagons across the river and then like
you just see like a woman go ah get
washed away and die and it's like well
she's dead that's so good or when uh
like uh Native Americans raid and just
kill a bunch of people and it's like
well they're dead yep that's just what
it was oh stop my toe I guess I'll die
for the record it's 1883. 83. there you
go 1883 drama we're getting 1886 all
sorts of years Ian's right don't make a
TV show with a year old's name we're
just throwing a 1976. it's just trolls
now no stop guys but it's crazy that uh
yo people just die all the time like
non-stop you just die you die of a
toothache yep yeah that's it
yeah right infections would kill us in
your blood you go septic and then you're
dead and really really miserable way as
well yeah hey you mentioned pole shifts
earlier how connected are they to a
human behavior and where do they come
from well that's a very hard segue yeah
what do you mean by that about as vague
as I asked I don't know but do you want
to segue into that now for sure I'm
burning I honestly so this is complete
pseudoscience but I look at how many
animals creatures insects birds whales
are on this planet that are completely
connected to to the poles in their in
their travels and I do wonder and this
is again pseudoscience but like it seems
like things are as crazy as ever and
people are acting a bit strange and I
don't know if it's because this internet
thing is causing us to go a little bit
nuts as we're staring at the screens not
getting enough vitamin D but I do wonder
if it's having an effect on us um and I
should look and if you give me a second
I'm going to bring up a certain verse
from the Bible I'm not some bible
thumper but there's something in it that
alludes to how the people are going to
behave in the end times are you familiar
with this yeah I think someone cited it
to us yesterday actually really yeah
read it um well there's a couple so
first of all let me start with this one
this is
um Isaiah 5 20. uh woe to those that
call evil good and good evil who put
Darkness for light and light for
Darkness who put bitter for sweet and
Sweet for bitter and this is in the
context of end times is this not the
upside clown war that we live in right
now actually now that you mention it
like that yeah and I'm an agnostic like
not a religious guy at all so let me do
one more 2 Timothy three but understand
this in the last days terrible times
will come for men will be lovers of
themselves lovers of money boastful
arrogant abusive disobedient to their
parents ungrateful Unholy unloving
unforgiving slanderous without
self-control brutal without the love of
good traitorous Reckless conceited
lovers of pleasure rather than the
lovers of God having a form of godliness
and themselves but denying its power
turn away from these oh that sounds like
the left
yeah uh y'all sounds like the worst
aspects of me when I'm letting myself
when I'm not controlling myself I can I
find myself doing it but so was there uh
uh is it is it um explaining when we
expect these things it says in the end
times and there that is very so that
that is so debatable but in my mind I'm
like what if there's these cycles of
cataclysms and The more I've been
studying this like so it goes from me
looking into like Cosmic impacts which I
undoubtedly do believe happen but the
more I'm looking into details as far as
sun cycles and geomagnetic pole shifts I
look at things like Elon Musk is talking
about how you need to go down the rabbit
hole of Ice uh ages and I've looked into
that and if you look at like certain
things like such as the mini Ice Age
which or the little ice age as it's
called from the year 1300 to 1850 550
years of global cooling approximately
two degrees Celsius 3.6 degrees
Fahrenheit famine around vast portions
of the world reduction in livestock
that's tied to solar Cycles as well as
the global or its belief that's one of
the speculated reasons but there's
something else and I'll quickly say this
the Roman warming period as it's called
which was increased warmth and
Mediterranean all the way through the UK
and that was same thing a two degree
estimated three or salsa great Celsius
or 3.6 degree Fahrenheit where there was
you know an abundance of Vineyards Roman
Vineyards in the UK and it was warmth
and it's tied to Sun cycles so my point
is is that like these things have
happened you never hear about in the
context of climate change sorry uh go
ahead Tim I just wanted to bring up a
story as soon as your point oh well
that's it I think that these are things
that are that need to be looked at and
then going back to like you know
geomagnetic having an influence on us
I'm like why would this these people
found it and again I'm not a bible
thumper but people thousands of years
ago wrote this sound and thought it was
incredibly important to preserve it and
it just gives me a weird feeling that
when I see that this mirrors our society
to a T and I don't want to sell Mr
doomsday guy but um what if it's related
to a geomantic pole shift the reduction
in and I don't know thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time